so thanks for the invitation to be here
and thank you for coming to this talk I
know it's not it's not your normal
computer science talk but maybe that's
part of the what would be good about it
so I I wanna I want to start by by
saying that I have been writing and
doing research about computer software
intellectual property protection for 30
years I wrote a paper in 1984 which
raised questions about how well
copyright would do in protecting
computer programs copyright doesn't
usually protect functionality and so
putting something functional into a body
of law that doesn't usually protect
functional things kind of seemed like it
was going to create some problems at the
same time I wrote a paper in 1990 about
patentability of software and why some
of the Supreme Court decisions had
decided that algorithms and other types
of computer innovations were too
abstract were like mental processes that
couldn't be protected and so maybe it
wasn't patentable maybe the patent
system that worked very well and maybe
the copyright system didn't work on it
very well so with mitch k4 and a couple
of other people i wrote a paper called
the manifesto and the legal protection
of computer programs in 1994 which said
maybe we should have a special form of
intellectual property protection
tailored to the kind of thing that
software is that never took off but at
least I wrote what I thought I've
written a lot of briefs in the software
IP cases including a brief in support of
Google's petition for certiorari at
least some of you may know that I write
a regular column for communications of
the ACM talking about things like the
Oracle be Google case and the
patentability of software but I want to
make sure that you know nobody pays me
I'm doing this completely on my own so
don't think that I'm like a Google stood
here ok I fought them really hard on the
Google book settlement so I really am an
independent person so I want to start by
talking a little bit before we get into
the cases that are most at issue right
now is I want to set the stage by by
talking a little bit more about why the
existing intellectual property regimes
just don't match up very well to the
nature of software that will help you
understand why it is that the courts
could get a little confused on some of
the issues and why they are struggling
to kind of reach a good conclusion on
some of the very complicated issues that
arise I'll try to talk to you also about
sort of what is it that Oracle is saying
it's going on here from a legal
standpoint what is school saying is
going on here from a legal standpoint so
some part of the value I've been trying
to serve the computing professionals
community is to try to translate what
our lawyers talking about because the
things that may strike you as the
relevant things aren't necessarily what
courts are focused on so to the extent
that you have insights about how courts
ought to look at these things I want to
suggest that there are ways for you to
try to let that information come out and
so I'll talk about the role of amicus
Cori are you a friend of the court
briefs that may be worth doing if you if
you care about this I'll talk about what
the Supreme Court is going to do I think
and what happens if they don't take the
case and then some issues that you might
want to consider so I've already kind of
indicated one of the problems with
copyrighted for computer programs is
copyright protects artistic and literary
works by things that are that are only
functional insofar as they convey
information or display in appearance the
functionality of most types of works
excludes them entirely from copyright in
the u.s. system and so source code
that's pretty well in the literary work
category where literary work just as a
work consisting of symbols words or
symbols but of course object code is a
functional process and that's a
something that copyright doesn't usually
do but Congress said oh well let's do it
anyway and then the question is what
happens
so clearly the copying exactly bit for
bit of programs is going to be
infringement there are things there
sometimes expressive conventionally
expressive elements for example video
games right the sort of the colors and
the movement and the songs and stuff
like that all of that stuff is kind of
conventionally like a kind of
audio-visual work and so so some cases
have involved copying a video game
graphics and the like but the question
that has bedeviled the courts for the
last 25 years or so is to what extent
are non literal elements of computer
programs eligible for protection by by
copyright law so a non-literal element
of a program might be an algorithm might
be a data structure might be the API
might be any one of a number of things
you know this better than me but part of
what we're trying to sort of figure out
is what structural features of computer
programs are expressive in a copyright
sense and what ones aren't and command
structures of user interfaces and
api's have been two of the places where
there's been quite a bit of litigation
although it died
for a while so I've talked now what why
the software is a misfit in terms of the
copyright system let me say a few more
things about why it's a misfit with
patents so software is a technology the
right it's a virtual machine if machines
are patentable then virtual machines
should be patentable right this sounds
really like logical the problem has been
that in respect of programs as writings
right the literary work metaphor well
there's a doctrine in patent law that
says printed matter can't be protected
by the patent system and so most most
works of literature for example would
flunk any effort to patent them by
saying it's a printed matter blah blah
blah and when the Patent Office first
was presented with programs the Patent
Office said looks like printed matter to
me
and so flush those out of the system but
of course even if you got a patent on a
particular program it would be pretty
easy to rewrite it so in fact what
people try to patent are things that are
more abstract elements of programs but
the question about whether or not those
more abstract elements are patentable
subject matter is something that the
Supreme Court did a lot of work on in
the 1970s calling into question the
patentability of algorithms and other
processes that may be implemented in
computer code but in fact our mental
processes step by step by step kind of
things so mental processes and abstract
ideas are patent doctrines that flush
out a lot of the elements of programs
from the from the patent system and
the Alice vs. Els Bank case which the
Supreme Court decided last June is a
decision that seems to call into
question a lot of software patents and
so those of us who watching what's going
on in the software patent arena are
saying courts strike them down one after
the other so it's not all of them and
gotten struck down but I would say
something in the neighborhood of 90 to
95% of the software patents have been
litigated lately our patents that are
getting flushed out of the system it's
not patentable subject matter either so
we have them this kind of contextual
situation where there's a lot of value
in computer programs but copyright
doesn't seem very well suited to it and
patents don't see very well suited to it
so what do we do about that so that's
kind of the background so another thing
that actually makes this all complicated
is this notion that there's kind of like
writings of authors over here and that's
the job of copyright and machines
manufacturers other technologies over
here and inventors of those novel and
non-obvious machines get patents but it
seems like right
they're like two different universes
right their copyright over here
copyright attaches automatically by
operation of law you don't have to apply
as you do for a patent it lasts a really
long time ninety-five years for
corporate authored works and patents if
you can get them will last no more than
20 years but you have to apply for them
and you have to sort of satisfy all
these requirements in order to get them
so you can see that there's a little bit
of temptation out there to try to extend
copyright protection to things that
probably oughta belong in the patent
system and because if you don't apply
for a patent then your innovation once
it becomes known is in the public domain
and free for everybody to use and so
I put up the Constitution here because
you can see that you can you can see
built into it this notion that there's
these two separate universes right
writings of authors that promote the
progress of science and and inventions
in the useful arts and this kind of word
respective again saying signals that
these two things are completely
different okay
so I've pretty much already covered this
so there's a case that was decided in
it turns out this case is like the
battleground right now on the issues
that were concerning ourselves with so
let me talk about it a little bit
because people have different
interpretations about what this case
means and I have a very distinct
position on this and other people have a
very distinct position on it so it turns
out to be pretty important so Charles
Sheldon came up with what he thought was
a brilliant idea for a new bookkeeping
system and so he he put together a set
of forms that would implement the system
and I wrote a little explanatory text to
begin with and published that as a book
then Baker also a bookkeeper decides to
write his own book and included in that
book forms that were substantially
similar to the forms in the Selden book
and so Selden's Widow sued him for sued
Baker for copyright infringement
claiming not only copyright protection
in the book and that the scope of
copyright in that book extended to the
system that was being implemented
through the forms but also copyright in
the system itself right so if you kind
of think about what a bookkeeping form
looks like it's got column
as a little headings and so the
particular selection and arrangement of
the columns and the headings were
thought by mrs. Selden to be part of the
book that was important commercially and
therefore when the when Baker came along
and stole the forms he should be
punished as an infringer and also that
anybody who was using bakers forms was
an infringer to this turned out to be
significant because there were 40
counties in Ohio that were using the
that Baker forms and so the liability
not only a baker but also of all the
people who are using the system was kind
of at stake and so it's a pretty
important thing so a trial judge in the
in the late 1860's ruled in favor of
Selden and Baker appealed so the Supreme
Court and actually quite readable
decision not many of the Supreme Court
decisions are readable but this one is
but the court said look Selden's
copyright in the book extends to his
explanation of the bookkeeping system
but not to the bookkeeping system itself
and the court seemed to perceive the
selection and arrangement of the forms
the headings and columns and so forth as
implementations of the system and
anybody was free the Supreme Court said
to to copy the bookkeeping system and
make their own forms to do the same kind
of work and the court spoke of the
bookkeeping system as a useful art which
you couldn't get protection from
copyright for that's only the
explanation or today we use the word
expression but part of what caused the
court to kind of raised the issue about
useful arts was that in
preface to Selden's book he talked about
having gone to the Patent Office and
tried to get a patent on his wonderful
invention well the guy who wrote the
opinion for the Supreme Court basically
said he's a patent lawyer he says you're
trying to get a pet you know the Patent
Office didn't give you right obviously
if the if you're suing for copyright
infringement you didn't get the patent
that you were that you tried to apply
for and so the Supreme Court said you
can't do that right the copyright then
has the role of protecting explanation
description and the like but not not the
systems that might be described therein
yes since it was turned down may very
well be that the Patent Office rejected
the patent on subject matter grounds as
I think the Supreme Court would do today
if a bookkeeping system was before it
however I know from having read the
brief submitted by Baker's lawyer to the
Supreme Court that one of the things
that the lawyers argued was that if
there's a gap between the patent system
and the copyright system so that
something like a bookkeeping system
isn't eligible for either that's a
matter for Congress right if Congress
thinks that things like bookkeeping
system needs some legal protection it's
up to Congress to do that not but that's
actually not the tack that the Supreme
Court took and Baker V Seldin instead
the court accepted that this might be
patent subject matter and basically said
it's a useful art if you're going to get
protection for that at all you got to
get a patent on it you can't use
copyright in order to do it and you see
there's the temptation again to stretch
copyright to reach something that's
valuable is something that's very
appealing and again we see that in some
of the some of the things that we some
of the issues in the
oral-b google case so the court says
there would be a surprise and a fraud on
the public if we allowed people to get
patent like protection for something
that's ineligible for for patent
protection and you can't get that from
copyright so again if this this case
kind of reinforces that categorical
exclusivity thing that I talked about
before right writings over here machines
over here and never the twain shall meet
except when computer programs come along
and mess everything up so the current
kind of battleground is the based on the
Copyright Act of 1976 that statute in
the most relevance says that copyright
subsists an original works of authorship
that have been fixed in a tangible
medium of expression so once you make
source code transform it into object
code that's the literary work that
copyright subsists in but section 102 B
is a really interesting provision it
says that in no cases copyright for an
original work of authorship extend to
any idea procedure process system method
of operation concept principle or
discovery regardless of how it's
embodied in the work yeah functional
versus writing distinction is there
anything from the history of like player
piano rolls or Allu mechanical loom
instructions that gives a useful
perspective here so the answer is the
wounds were never copyright subject
matter so that didn't come out now if
you in fact make an original design with
a weaving the weaving the kind of the
pictorial elements of the weaving could
be protected by copyright but not the
not the punch card that embodies the
design it never came up
okay now piano rules actually did come
up
but here's what happened with that so it
was not the case that the piano rolls
themselves were claimed copyright
protection in but rather there was a
case of about the turn of the century
the last one
where somebody was making piano rules of
popular music and the question was
whether or not the piano roll was an
infringement of the musical composition
Supreme Court besides you can't read it
so what am you can't read it right so
because remember like what what does you
know what uh what the most works of
authorship do you can see them right so
in this case and the Supreme Court said
musical composition is defined in terms
of notes on paper this is a note on
paper and so decided that that was not
an infringement the next year Congress
passed an amendment to the copyright
statute extending protection to musical
works so that mechanical reproductions
were so the mechanical the sound
recording people had to pay the
musicians for that but it wasn't until
1971 that Congress passed a law protect
extending protection to sound recordings
so that is another chapter but it's a
very good question so thank you for that
but this question that I'm interested in
and that is at the heart of the debate
that we'll be talking about is what are
these process procedures system method
of operation words mean now the
legislative history of this provision
indicates that Congress was very
expressed they added it to the statute
in order the computer program copyrights
would not be too broad didn't say what
it meant and unfortunately the group of
people who studied a computer program a
copyright issue
did not include a single person with any
technical training whatsoever so you
have a group of people who didn't know
what they were talking about writing I
think it said well so they work it so
he's gonna be easy to apply copyright to
it's like yeah right anyway so the other
concept that actually I should mention
is what is is this concept called a
merger of idea and expression so a
fundamental part of copyright law not
only in the US but in the world is that
copyright only extends to the the
author's expression and not to the ideas
but there are occasionally situations in
which there are just not very many ways
to say something or to do something to
depict something and in that case idea
and expression merge and if they merge
then there's no protection for the
merged entity it's only it's a you know
maybe there'll be something else that
can be protected but not that merged
element okay so the two main positions
are that section 102 B means nothing
more than abstract ideas are
unprotectable this strikes me as a
specious interpretation of a statute
that has eight words of exclusion and
essentially sometimes the courts read
those other seven phrases out of the
statute and so it has been my lifelong
challenge to try to get the courts to
basically pay attention to those words
and the question also about whether
merger is something that only can apply
merger doctrine can only apply when at
the very beginning of the plaintiffs
creation process there wasn't any other
way to do it so that's a there's a
debate about whether or not merger can
happen for example over time or whether
some things even if they were creative
from the get-go
in fact constrain the design decisions
of
later people so that it shouldn't be
protected at all
so that's the that's that's kind of just
setting this up I swear to God the next
slide I'm gonna get - all right let me
Google oh never mind the previous slide
that a cookbook is not protectable no
recipes aren't protectable but a
creative creative selection and
arrangement recipes my favorite
chocolate cake my favorite lemon cake
and so forth those things can be printed
that the cookbook as a compilation can
be protected but no none of the recipes
can be rearranged them in a different
compilation right so that's the that's
the rule about that okay so let me talk
about what happened in the oracle v
google case so oracle sued Google in
2010 shortly after taking overs and
Microsystems and the allegation so there
were patent claims in the case and I
think Oracle initially thought it was
going to win in the patent claims but a
jury ruled against the patent claims so
all they have left in the case is these
copyright claims the the claim at the
trial court level was that that Google
had copied the structure sequence an
organization SS o of the Java 37 of the
java api packages and in 2012 the
district court decided that those 37
java api s were not protectable by
copyright law and this is kind of the
nub of what the rationale was the SS o
of the java api is were in its view a
command structure and that command
structure was a method of operating a
computer in order to achieve a certain
result
the court also adopted the notion of
idea/expression merger saying that the
rules of Java syntax dictate and certain
names have to be identical or things
won't interoperate and so the there was
a merger of idea and expression and the
court accepted and made findings
actually about Google having used those
Java API so that Java apps could run on
Android so that you needed them for
compatibility purposes this is important
because there's some prior cases
involving compatibility type of issues
and so api's have been treated in some
other cases as unprotectable elements of
computer programs but trial judge also
noted that Java programmers expected to
be able to use those names and commands
and maeap eaj specifications if they
were writing apps for the Android
platform so the Court of Appeals for the
Federal Circuit last year decided that
that Oracle was right and Google was
wrong and these are this is the core
part of what the court had to say on
these issues so there was no merger of
idea and expression in this case because
at the time that Suns engineers designed
the Java API in the first place they had
lots of choices about names they had
lots of choices about how to structure
things and so that creativity was enough
originality to to make the api's
protectable expression not merged and so
also the court really says that there's
just if there's only one way to do
something then then that's the situation
a merger and there were at least three
of the Java packages that the court that
even the court of appeals thought you
can hardly do anything in the Java
language without those three core
packages
so maybe those core packages would be
something where there was merger but
everything else Google had a chance to
do things differently and it chose to
copy and freeride on the value that Sun
now Oracle was the owner of the
intellectual property rights in so the
remember the trial judge said that the
the java api headers for four methods
and also the classes were a command
structure that was a method of operation
excluded from protection at 102 B the
Court of Appeals says that that what 102
B is about is the unprotect ability of
abstract ideas and because this these
java api eyes are specific and concrete
right they they look like words and
symbols that they in fact were there was
no they weren't method of operation they
weren't excluded from protection and
made the claim that google's argument
was really trying to undermine copyright
protection for computer programs
altogether and throw everything over
into the patent bin and the court said
can't do that and there the court said
there's no interoperability or no
compatibility exception to copyright
protection so Google may be able to
raise interoperability issues when the
case goes back down to the trial court
for further proceedings under a fair use
defense but it's not relevant at all to
the copyright ability of the Java API to
begin with so that's the core stuff a
couple of other things that the court
did that are important so at the trial
court level the case was litigated as
what I call an SSL case right the
structure sequence and organization of
the java api is there wasn't a
of any literal copying of code the
appellate lawyer that that wrote the
brief to the Federal Circuit decided to
go whole hog and say that the that the
method headers in fact are lines of code
and so seven thousand lines of code
we're stolen by Google and so not only
that but they cop they copied the SSO of
the of the Java classes and so all of
this is just terrible terrible terrible
and I think the Federal Circuit was
affected by the argument and Oracle's
brief that look they negotiated for a
license so they knew that they needed a
license and then when they didn't get
the deal that they wanted they decided
to copy it anyway and so bla bla bla so
the failed negotiations with son is
something that tainted the view of the
the Federal Circuit on this particular
issue and even more damning from the
standpoint of the Federal Circuit was
the notion that that Google by copying
37 of the Java API is and not the whole
set had actually designed it to be
incompatible with Java and that was
another thing so this oh I'm trying to
be interoperable oh I'm trying to be
compatible as a bunch of hooey from the
standpoint of the Federal Circuit who
thinks that basically you know you
designed it to be incompatible so you
can't raise compatibility defenses if in
fact you designed it for this purpose
and one thing that actually the the
trial court had said was the java api is
that he was hearing about and was ruling
about look to him more like patent
subject matter than copyright subject
matter and the judge noted that actually
both son and oracle had gotten patent
on api's which sorta seemed made it seem
like it was patent subject matter so to
the extent that Oracle was claiming
copyright in it right the old Baker V
Seldin
approach would say oh if it's a patent
subject matter then it can't be
protected by copyright it's kind of two
different worlds and two different
regimes but the Federal Circuit said
well doesn't matter if they're
patentable and copyright Able's nobody
says that you can't get both
well actually the Supreme Court does but
who's counting so so Google has asked
the Supreme Court to review the Federal
Circuit's ruling and the main arguments
that it's making is that this case is
one of exceptional importance of
software industry there's a conflict
among the circuits there are decisions
we live in the Ninth Circuit their
decisions from the Third Circuit and
from the Federal Circuit that are at
odds with decisions in the Ninth Circuit
and the Second Circuit and so one of the
ways and one of the reasons the Supreme
Court takes cases from time to time is
because the law is supposed to be
uniform throughout the United States of
America you can't have kind of the
patent law interpreted this way in in
California in this way in New York you
basically have one uniform law so the
conflict of the circuits is as to the
interpretation of this section 102 B
especially the process procedures system
method of operation exclusion and the
interpretation of the merger doctrine
that's significance of interoperability
and whether or not API is a really more
patent subject matter than copyrights
subject matter it just so happens that
the interpretation of section 102 B was
an issue that was before the supreme
court 20 years ago and they split four
to four in the Lotus reborn case and so
the kind of what does 102 B mean has
been kind of hanging out there for for
20 years and so one of the reasons why
the supreme court may take the case
back that they punted right they kicked
the can down the road and now the cans
coming back to visit them and there were
several amicus briefs in support of
Google's petition so Oracle of course
says no need to take this case so the
the argument that they start with is the
notion that what Google did is copy
source code and there's no circuit split
about the copyrightability of source
code so you don't need to take it there
may be some circuit splits on other
aspects of this but not about source
code and of course Oracle thinks that
the Federal Circuit correctly
interpreted section 102 B and the merger
doctrine the court said you know Google
can make a fair use defense and raise
stuff but Oracle says look this is not
right for supreme court review because
usually if there's a issue that's still
pending in the case you you send it back
to the lower court to have further
proceedings blah blah blah and then
final judgment you you you appeal that
and they respond to the patent copyright
subject matter issue is saying no
problem to have it be post patentable
and copyrightable big deal so there were
there were seven Supreme there were
seven amicus Korea friend-of-the-court
briefs
so the Electronic Frontier Foundation
organized one 477 computer scientists so
if you want to you want to follow
through at some point you don't like
this decision either talk to e F F
public interest firm in based in DC
public knowledge filed a brief
hewlett-packard Red Hat and Yahoo did
and these other people and meet the the
one amicus brief that was filed in
support of Oracle's deny cert was the
free software foundation you kind of go
blood here's what here's here's the
here's the thing they're afraid
eben Moglen is afraid of what the
Supreme Court will do with this issue
because they couldn't even figure out
lotus free Borland and lotus tree
Portland was a pretty simple case so
they're worried that that the supreme
court could really screw things up bad
so Supreme Court Supreme Court doesn't
have to take cases as I'm sure you know
so sometimes the Supreme Court asks the
Solicitor General that's the kind of
chief legal officer that relates it
files briefs with the Supreme Court to
review the case and make a
recommendation about what the supreme
court could should take it so one of the
data points that I saw is that if if the
supreme court asks the SG to take the to
review the case that makes up 46 more
times more likely that the court will
take it then if they don't refer it to
the SG and they have two three options
right one is to ask the SG one is just
deny it outright and one is to say okay
we're going to take it and what is so
what is certiorari certiorari is is a
writ a document old old labels home
means bring the record forward so up the
core if the Supreme Court issues a writ
of certiorari they're issuing an order
to the appellate court to bring the
whole record forward so the Supreme
Court can go through the whole thing
anyway if if the case if the Supreme
Court takes it which will probably know
by the by June
if they take it they're going to they'll
it will be heard next fall so what
happens at the Supreme Court denied cert
well what happens is the case will be
remanded to have further proceedings
about the fair use defense and Google
came within one vote of a fair use
ruling into a jury back years ago the
Federal Circuit decision is not really
going to bind any other circuit because
it doesn't usually hear copyright cases
the only reason it heard the copyright
case in this particular situation is
because there was a patent claim in the
case at the beginning so usually
copyright cases would go to the Ninth
Circuit in the Ninth Circuit case law on
AP is actually not consistent with what
the Federal Circuit did but whatever but
what you're gonna see is some litigation
right at the Supreme Court denied cert
then that will mean there'll be a lot
more lawsuits about command structures
api's and the like and so it'll call
into question these decisions from 20
years ago that seemed to say that api's
are not protectable so I said I think
they'll take the case and I protect
they're gonna I predict they're gonna
reverse but you know you just you never
know so how do courts decide things like
this will they look at the statue and
they try to interpret the statute they
look at the legislative history if the
statute isn't exactly clear they look at
the prior case law and then they engage
in a kind of pattern matching exercise
and then try to think about side of like
what impact is this going to have on
third parties that's one of the reasons
why i'm because corey i briefs are
really important in Supreme Court cases
because it gives an opportunity for
people who don't have this skin directly
in the game right they're not they're
not parties to the litigation but boy
this is going to have big impact on me
this other guy and this other guy and so
take that into account Supreme Court
when you make your ruling yeah as a
Solicitor General spoken yeah takes two
to three months
so the Supreme Court asked the SG to
look at it On January 12 I know this
exact date and so it's going to take two
or three months so we'll know something
I would say late late March to late
April timeframe and who is the Solicitor
General and which way did they have a
thumb on the scale of any is actually
the Solicitor General of the United
States
he's a very good lawyer um he won the
MGM versus roxtor case before the
Supreme Court so he's been known shall I
say to take the entertainment industry
position on certain things but that's
you know he was a lawyer representing
blah blah blah so so don't it's just
interesting information I don't know
that the the the motion picture industry
has any skin in this particular game but
of course they care a lot about what
copyright but the Supreme Court says
about copyright law so they might weigh
in on in some respect or another now the
there is part of the reason it takes a
couple of three to three months to get
the SGS brief happening is that there's
an intergovernmental consultation so
people in the White House people in the
Justice Department people in this
department people in that OSTP can weigh
in so there's this kind of
intergovernmental consultation and then
the Solicitor General's Office after
having consulted with everybody
essentially makes the best judgment on
behalf of the administration for that's
a good thing the connections between
video games and comic books and movies
seems to suggest that there might be
some interest on the part of the
entertainment industry in the outcomes
yeah but these I mean this is not a
video game case right I mean it's not
even close to a video game case um I
just don't think they care that much but
I I could be wrong they haven't they
haven't weighed in so far ok so again
part of this pattern-matching thing is
sort of let's let's talk about so
the chief cases on which Oracle relies
and then the chief cases that Google's
relying on just so you can kind of see a
little bit of what that pattern matching
looks like so it was a case in 1986
called Wayland versus jazz Lowe where a
guy who wrote a dental laboratory
program was alleged to infringe by
copying the structure sequence and
organization of certain elements of the
program some file and data structures
and some ways that certain subroutines
operated and the Third Circuit Court of
Appeals which is kind of New Jersey
Pennsylvania based made this analogy
that software is a literary work
copyright protects a structured sequence
and organization of literary works and
so it should protect the sso of computer
programs
- and there's merger of idea and
expression only if there's no other way
to perform a function and since there
were other data structures and other
file structures in other ways you could
have organized the subroutine then that
copying was copying a part of the
expression of the program and the Third
Circuit also said you know if we don't
give strong protection in the computer
programs the industry will fall apart
and that would be terrible there's also
a case called American Dental
Association versus death Delta Dental
and what happened in this case is the
American Dental Association had
developed a coding system coding system
ding-ding-ding at should've ran runs
some bells in 102 B land but the the
judge decided that that the standard
names that the a DA had come up with for
dental procedures and associated that
with a number right so this tooth has a
certain number and if you have two
minutes to Minich cavity on this side
it's one number of cavity on that side
it's a different number and basically
the coding system was developed to
facilitate insurance sort of processing
of claims so Delta copied not any of the
text not in the explanation in the ad a
book but copied the taxonomy of names of
the dental procedures and the numbers
representing the names and then had its
own guide that it was making available
to dentists to a DA su Delta Dental and
the Seventh Circuit Court of Appeals in
1997 said that the names of the dental
procedures and the numbers were
copyrightable because there were a
number of different ways you could do it
and so there's no merger of
idea/expression and it's not the kind of
system that is ineligible for protection
under section 102 B so that's the that's
that's their cases the main case that
the trial judge relied on is this Lotus
versus Borland case that came down in
1994 from the First Circuit Court of
Appeals which is based in Boston so
borland had developed its own
spreadsheet program to compete with
Lotus 1-2-3 and it had a native
interface for those people who were
starting with from scratch using a
spreadsheet program but in order to woo
over to the Borland program some people
who had been familiar with Lotus 1-2-3
and had constructed macros in the the
macro command language that that Lotus
made available to its customers decided
to keep two for that emulation interface
the exact same commands had to be in
exactly the same order in order for in
for the emulation interface for the
macros to execute properly so
the district court said there's creative
creativity in the selection arrangement
instead of copy you should have you
could use replicate or you could use
this word and you could have used that
word for paste you could have used this
word or that word whatever whatever
whatever so because there were lots of
alternatives there was no merger of idea
and expression and the section 102 B is
really only about the unprotect ability
of abstract ideas
the first Circuit Court of Appeals
reversed and said that the command
hierarchy the structure sequence and
organization of the commands for Lotus
1-2-3 commands in the emulation
interface that that that that was an
unprotectable method of operation
excluded from protection under 102 B in
that court likened the the commands to
the buttons on a VCR so you you know you
press this one and it it's a method of
operating the VCR to do this function in
that function so that analogy of the
kind of the you know you press that
command and it does this function right
seem like a strong argument and so the
court decided that actually that was an
unprotectable method of operation the
Supreme Court heard oral argument in the
case justice Stevens unfortunately work
used himself I think because he owned
some IBM stock and IBM owned Lotus at
the time so they just said we can't
decide this because we're we're split
four to four to four and so the issue
has been kind of hanging on there are
two other cases that are actually
relevant I'm sorry as I'm talking a lot
I hope this is packed there are two
other cases that are worth mentioning
because these are the cases that involve
interoperability issues right so the
Second Circuit Court of Appeals which
was the one based in New York and
actually is very influential generally
speaking and copyright cases was faced
with a case
we're all Thai and Computer Associates
both made scheduling programs that would
interoperate with IBM system operating
systems and so the they both had
compatibility components to their
software and the there were structural
similarities in the list of services and
in the parameter list of the two
programs and the question was whether or
not those structural similarities would
give rise to infringement and the court
decided not that there was no
infringement because that
Computer Associates and alt I were both
constrained in their design decisions
about how they structured the
compatibility component because of the
constraints from the programs that they
had to interoperate with so this is a
place where they didn't use the word
interface they didn't use the word API
but but the language that the court used
was to say that when you are constrained
in your design decisions that you can't
do something any other way then and you
want to be compatible with somebody else
then it's okay to copy that which is
necessary to achieving interoperability
and so that was then the kind of the
decision in 1992 that kind of set the
standard it criticized that Whelan
versus Jaz Lowe case among other things
for its in inaccurate understanding of
computer science and the court basically
said the other court was completely
wrong and so in the 20-some years after
the author I decisions everybody but the
Third Circuit follows the the Altai case
and the important case in the Ninth
Circuit is the case called Sega versus
accolade so accolade made video games
and most of those video games ran on a
PC platform because the Sega Genesis
platform was really popular and there
were lots and lots and lots of things
out there they wanted to be able to
adapt their games so that they could run
on the Sega platform so accolade
acquired copies of the software in the
machine and in the video game and
reverse engineered them in order to
extract the information necessary to
then re-implement in independently
written code for the for the the genesis
version of the accolade games now this
didn't come up to the courts as saying
that the API that was embedded in the in
the program was protectable by copyright
law that wasn't what was being argued at
all in the case but rather Sega was
arguing that because the process of
reverse engineering the code in order to
extract the information about the
interface was copying of a computer
program that it was infringement it was
infringement just to reverse engineer
and Knight Circuit said Oh baloney to
that said that it was a fair use to
rebirth to make copies for reverse
engineering purposes when you were
trying to extract information necessary
to achieve interoperability and in that
case the court spoke of the interface
for the Sega programs as unprotectable
procedures under section 102 be a few
years later the Ninth Circuit in another
case reaffirmed its its ruling in the
Sega vehicle a case again talking about
the interface as an unprotectable
procedure under section 102 B now the
Federal Circuit is supposed to follow
Ninth Circuit precedent when it reviews
cases because it doesn't have any
jurisdiction over copyrights it has
jurisdiction over patents but
occasionally they get a copyright case
but when they get a copyright case
they're supposed to follow the the
circuit rulings and so the Federal
Circuit decided that sake of the
accolade case didn't say what it said
and so that's one of the reasons they
should get reversed and so that's anyway
these this is a this is another one of
the cases that that Google is relying on
okay so I mean the big picture issues
are ones that are probably more salient
to you than all the stuff I've been
talking about but but you kind of look
at the big picture as is the Supreme
Court gonna look at the big picture I
think they know this is a pretty big
deal and part of actually what's
important about this case is that the
rationale that the Federal Circuit used
in rejecting Google's defense calls into
question all of the interoperability
rulings that have been out there for the
last couple of decades so it's important
to sort of understand that you know the
this can of worms had been kind of
closed for a while and this case is kind
of reopening it and I'm like going deja
vu all over again I've written briefs
like this before but of course I you
know the issues are not easy
partly because right we put computer
programs in the copyright law without
really anybody
I'm the computing community having
anything to say about what the scope of
protection should be and so you know you
look at something like the you know the
method headers and the method
specifications of Java and you sort of
say boy it looks a little more like
copyright subject matter than it looks
like patent subject matter I think this
was also one of the problems that the
Supreme Court had in the Lotus Evora Lin
case so if you look at those commands so
the user interface commands of Lotus
1-2-3 it's like selection and
arrangement of words looks like coming
right to me and the court some members
of the court couldn't see that the
selection and arrangement of those
commands wasn't just oh I'm just going
to be creative today it was a
fundamental part of the functionality of
the Lotus macro system and because of
that it should have been outside of the
scope of copyright protection that's the
way I wrote to the First Circuit that's
what I wrote to the Supreme Court way
back when and it didn't take so I'm
trying to try it up bad again and see
whether I can win this one did the
Google lawyers make a fundamental
mistake and saying that it was code it's
just interface files they actually don't
perform any functionality so this is a
pen okay so
Oracle has a really good lawyer he's one
of the best lawyers in the country and
he changed the nature of the
conversation so what I mean by that is
that when the case was tried before the
trial court the trial court says and
this is actually a finding of fact below
is that there was no copying of code
that Google reimplemented everything and
independently written code and so
there's no copying of code it's a
structured sequence an organization case
right they reimplemented the the
specification the commands in and
different in different
code but by the time the case went to
the court of appeals they got a
different lawyer different lawyer says
hey I see these words in the in the
source code let's let's make this into a
literal copying case
now usually courts don't let you do that
right so if if if you argued one thing
down here and you didn't win you can't
sort of say oh well that's mean let me
kind of recharacterize what the paths
are but in this case not only did Josh
Rosencrantz do it but he succeeded at it
and so and that's what the suggestions
yes okay they get to issue the rulings
whether you like it or not so so one of
the things that Google is going to have
to do if the Supreme Court takes it
Google's gonna have to be very very
sharp to distinguish between the method
headers which are not executable code
and executable code that's actually they
did that all right Oracle didn't even
argue literal copying at the trial court
level they only argued it at the
appellate court level is it even
possible so this is interesting
yeah you can but you then have to
disclaim it altogether you have to
abandon your claim of copyright and so
you know this is one of those things
where where if you say to everybody oh
please implement this all please do
don't write your own code yeah yeah we
don't stand for copyright protection for
api's we don't stand for patents
although they got some anyway but
whatever thing is that they did that and
public forum back in the 1980s and early
90s they filed briefs in the Altai case
and in the Lotus V Borland case so they
were active players but of course you
know just because somebody owned an
asset once and said oh come play on my
on my backyard all the time and then
they sell the house and somebody else
buys it they say no you can't you can't
come in here as a swingset anymore right
it's like you the question of whether or
not son can be bound right or the Oracle
can be bound by statements that son
might have made about this it's not it's
not clear it's not it's not going to be
one of the it's not going to be one of
the top things but I'm sure that
peppered throughout at least some of
them Mika scurry ideas are going to be
statements about hey you know son used
to say XY and see it son used to say XY
and Z at something you can't bind Oracle
to it no you can't but you have to do it
more expressly you can't just go to into
so they didn't okay base what they would
say is that copyright protection for API
is really a bad idea
for the job guys no we don't want yeah
that would that would have gotten you
closer to it but um anyway the point is
that that that's probably not going to
be something that's going to win the
case um so part of what of course the
courts have to deal with is the statute
and the case law and you know they can
do some big picture stuff but you know
one of the questions that yeah that is
kind of out there is if you have all
these Java programmers who know how
essentially the speak in Java
by implementing these api's do you have
to do they have to learn everything from
scratch in order to write for the
Android platform that's you know
essentially that's what Oracle is
arguing is that they should have made up
their entirely their own their own api's
and not used not used any of this any of
the Java ones yes in the early days of
Java other was a dispute between Sun and
Microsoft because Microsoft had changed
some implementations not not the API but
we're doing things now is that relevant
so yes and no it's not relevant to the
copyright issues in this case because
the context within which that dispute
was being part of the kind of antitrust
claim that was being made against
against Microsoft by the Department of
Justice mostly so the claim that Sun was
making at that time was not about
copyright was not about intellectual
property so much as saying that this
that by by forking by fragmenting by
vice by essentially not making things
fully job fully compatible that they
were actually it was another strategy to
monopolize the software market so it was
a different legal context than the case
that we're talking about today yeah this
is the argument something like this does
not promote the progress of science and
useful or
it said is that argument gaining any
traction yeah early it'll be a lot of
what's going to get argued so pretty
much every brief well say well promote
the progress of science and useful arts
better if you rule my way
and so part of actually what the court
has to deal with is these kind of
self-interested statements right so you
want to say oh well the startups are
really gonna be hurt by this and kind of
spring cards yeah right
you care about that a lot I know so
that's why Amica scurry eye briefs
actually then provide an opportunity for
the court to get some not completely
disinterested obviously but at least
some feedback so if in fact there are
startup companies and organizations that
represent startup companies who file
into me because curry i briefed in
support of google's claim then google's
brief when it says oh well this is gonna
this is really gonna have a bad impact
on startups then it actually will be
much more plausible then if then if they
do the other thing so so what will
happen actually a lot of what the it's
an interesting stuff that at least for
somebody like me is what's going to
happen when it comes to who is oracle
gonna try to line up as amicus curiae in
support of them right because they are
not so you know microsoft will be a
friend than that one but who else will
be who else so they'll be around trying
to get they'll probably try to get some
computer scientists to file on the other
side to kind of offset the kind of 77
the FF rounded up what's the connection
with this and instruction setting
because the am doll or the intel x86 so
here's the thing the the case law is not
entirely clear and I think the
literature more generally isn't entirely
clear about whether all API should be
treated the same or whether some api's
might be protectable and some might not
be okay so what we have and let's say
the Sega vs. accolade case it
an example of something where accolade
reverse-engineered it extracted certain
information it then reimplemented it in
code that then allowed their their games
to work on that on that platform that's
a very specific interface and you know
different cases involve different kinds
of interfaces and it isn't clear that
all API should be treated the same
what is clear that as at least some of
the cases have have ruled that interface
procedures are that are necessary for
interoperability are unprotectable
elements of computer programs and
there's one case also where so company
called connect expand emulation software
platform so the people who had Sony
Playstation games could play those games
on the kinetics emulation platform and
they were not fully compatible with all
the PlayStation stuff they were only
compatible with so many gen blah blah
blah there's another case you know
involving Nintendo and Atari games and
this is like different kinds of
interoperability situations have been
presented before but it's not like
there's kind of like complete
consistency so you know in in Europe
they more directly as a kind of a
statutory matter thought about
interfaces and instead of saying as a
lot of people wanted them to say that
interfaces aren't protectable by
copyright law they say insofar as
interfaces are ideas or principles they
are unprotectable by copyright law
leaving to the courts the decision about
in what circumstances are those
interfaces protectable by copyright law
or not so it opened the door to
a fight about this particular thing but
again there's been a lot of litigation
on these issues in the United States but
it kind of calmed down right there was
like it's time went from about 1986 when
a Whelan versus jazz low came down to
1992 there was like huge storms of of
litigation and big fights I
I gave talks at a lot of technical
conferences during that time to try to
help people kind of understand what was
really going on but after the all Thai
decision came down and the all Thai
decision sort of said some things that
basically propagated out and so things
calm down and now the Federal Circuit's
ruling is opening things up again for
further complications is it a sort of
statute of limitations on this and are
in a sense remember that one of the
things that the copyright law if you
were ever in prison that you have to you
can't just let it stand and so you know
what son's behavior you know Oracle's
for reversing son's behavior seems like
to a certain extent a bait-and-switch so
there is a statute of limitations of
three years which you have to bring a
claim of copyright infringement within
three years unfortunately I think that I
mean Google would've loved to get out of
this case the statute of limitations
grande there's another kind of doctrine
called a stopple and another kind of
doctrine called latch so laches is like
if you wait and wait and wait and wait
and then suddenly you know somebody
makes a gazillion dollars off something
and then you say okay well now I'm gonna
cash in you know that's just a doctrine
that usually says if you delay too long
you know even if the statute of
limitations hasn't run that's one thing
but the Supreme Court just this last
year decided laches doesn't apply in
that's out the window estoppel is a kind
of a firmer thing right so I told you
it's okay for you to do this and then
you do it and then I come back later and
I sue you for it
estoppel is actually then you're stopped
from you can't bring a claim if you kind
of told people it's okay before now
there's a kind of a little bit of flavor
of estoppel here because of the
statements that the Sun people had been
making and also Jonathan Schwartz
testified at trial that he was fine with
Google having implemented the the Java
API so it may be that the Supreme Court
will take a more favorable view about
funds prior statements but I'll tell you
it didn't go over with the Federal
Circuit at all so how does the giant
pile of infringers play here I have an
Android phone
am i infringing yes all right
if Google is an infringer so is every
device maker that has an android
platform so is everybody who owns a
phone they are equally as much
infringers as s Google would be because
the codes embedded right it might I'm
gonna raise it so I go there to less
than ten minutes left so you in the back
emphasize that the consumer by the
agency an infringement well what about
the mobile carriers they would all be
infringers to Android well though that
will probably happen at the Supreme
Court level I think that they did I
think they didn't win oh I think it
didn't want to weigh in at the federal
circuit level I mean one thing that
lawyers know that other
is the Federal Circuit doesn't really
like amicus Korea what I agree of sin
especially doesn't like them from
professors and so I I got cited twice
for propositions that in fact I felt I
don't have as my mind put on my
proposition so it's like very cute
that's it so haven't so a decision for
Oracle how would that affect Android the
Android ecosystem outside of the United
States well so copyright laws exist in
other countries too so Oracle could try
to take the fight to other countries you
know I think at some point if they win
before the Supreme Court which lord
knows I hope they don't but if they do I
think the case will settle
you